the actress sophia bush who is that i
have no idea but apparently she's a
somewhat well-known actress she just
posted to her instagram
that that not pumping little boys
full of little girl hormones not pumping
little kids
full of cross-sex hormones and
mutilating their bodies
is tantamount to murder
yes hashtag trans kids are under attack
across the country
ar i guess arkansas just banned them
from accessing health care oh they can't
oh no they can't they can't get their
annual checkup they can't go to the
hospital if they have
appendicitis they oh no they have health
care uh
ar just won't uh won't allow them to it
won't allow
pervert parents to pump their kids full
of cross-sex hormones
this is tantamount to murder kids will
tell us who they are
it's our job to support them not
demonize or harm them no it's our job to
raise them and educate them and kids
won't tell us who they are because i
told my mother i was batman when i was
four years old
kids will tell us who they are no no if
if you are relying on kids to teach you
about the world and to educate you then
something has gone very wrong in your
life you are
you are living an inverted sort of life
but it this does bring i mean who cares
what some ridiculous actress says
there are three positions that you can
take on this transgender issue
and it involves a whole lot more than
just this issue of
people who are confused about their sex
which is as a psychological matter a
very small number of people as a social
contagion it's getting
bigger but there are three positions you
can have the one
is the the first one is the leftist
position which is men can be women
and therefore we ought to be able to
mutilate anyone we want
if we want to pump adults full of
hormones and chop off their body parts
that's
totally fine that's their choice that's
wonderful we we should do that actually
and if kids want to do that then we
should indulge kids in that too
that's the leftist position then there
is the call it the libertarian position
which is men cannot be women but hey who
am i to judge
you do you i mean look i think men can't
be women but maybe you think men can be
women and so you know really
who's to say so you should mutilate
adults
but you shouldn't mutilate children
because they haven't reached the age of
consent
and so you got to wait for them to
decide to harm themselves
and then once they want to harm
themselves then they can do that
libertarian position third position is
the conservative position which is
men cannot be women and therefore we
should not encourage this
and therefore we should not mutilate
anyone
this is the position of dr paul mchugh
who or at least in his practice this is
his position he was one of the pioneers
of the gender reassignment surgery
the very sort of mutilation that we're
talking about he did this at johns
hopkins
and he stopped doing it he shut he shut
that down because he realized it wasn't
providing any medical benefit
and it was wrong to do
i would strongly recommend the
conservative position here i think a lot
of conservatives who want to be like
nice guys and you know they don't want
to tell people what to think and
hey come on it doesn't affect me man or
whatever they they believe
that by arguing the number two position
the the libertarian position
that you know just don't do it to kids
yeah men can't really be women but
whatever
adults should be able to do whatever
they want so just don't do it to kids
they think
that that is going to stave off
the leftist position that we should be
able to do it to everybody including
pumping little kids full hormones
it won't that second permissive position
is just going to grant the premises that
the first one relies on
there is such a thing as reality we can
know certain things about reality
through
our faculties of reason we can know
certain things about the moral universe
like doctors shouldn't mutilate
patients we can know that through our
moral conscience which is a judgment of
reason
and if we're going to abandon our
faculties of reason in our moral
conscience
then we've just given the game away to
the leftists who believe that they can
redefine reality however they see fit
you are not staving off what what you
feel
is the the really bad part of this which
is really the worst part of it the the
mutilating kids you're not staving that
off by
adopting the live and let live you do
you position you have to
grow the cojones to stay
it's a kind of an interesting metaphor
to use in this topic you have to be able
to grow those body parts a spine too
would be a good one
to be able to state truths and have the
confidence
to stand by those truths in the public
square and to stand by those truths
through self-government where we make
our own laws rather than surrender the
field
to the radicals who are who are
engaging in vicious vicious behaviors
that are ruining countless lives now
including the lives
of children if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there